listen to me okay your mother needs to
manage her weight or there can be some
real problems
oh the longitude number the father old
[__]
[Applause]
now who's the doctor
it's totally legal these doctors don't
prescribe medical marijuana to anyone
man what do I tell them I need it for it
doesn't matter
they want to give you prescription
that's how they get paid just make
something up
hey Mr Washington welcome Hey doctor or
I'm going to ask you a couple questions
what
age
as in uh as in I got it need lots of
weed to get rid of it
okay okay AIDS
um wow all right uh are you are you sure
you're not suffering from anything else
like you know back pain nope anxiety
cool as a cucumber how about insomnia
sleep like a baby
with AIDS okay Mr Washington let's just
slow your roll for a second here if you
had AIDS then I would have to verify it
by saying test results whereas if you
have back pain or anxiety or anything
else that I can't test for then I can
give you this prescription for cannabis
right now oh understand oh yeah I see I
guess my bad okay so leprosy no no
because if you had leprosy I'd have to
quarantine you ouch what do you no okay
I see your fingers falling off don't do
that though that's not gonna work scurvy
nope Ricketts what no consumption no Mr
Washington something from this Century
schizophrenia no you don't have
schizophrenia just you keep it simple
please
what the hell is that I don't know what
that is a fish hook in my lip just pick
something off this list I can't reach it
why not paralyzed
does your face hurt Mr Washington yeah
then this should help
ahead of us every single time
dignanigans
[Music]
foreign
against
[Music]
dialogue without nylon absolutely I feel
like they're in my head
[Music]
foreign
against
me
dignanigans
[Music]
[Applause]
gentlemen
exploded nut syndrome is a condition
indicated by the presence of exploded
nuts which yours are
by the way I saw your show last night
amazing
Mr Lewis
thank you for coming in
with your Associates
I know this is hard to hear but we need
to make some serious decisions about
your mother's health
let's be honest she is getting on in
years oh
sad okay I see how it is I see how it is
well yo mama so oh her last name is
osaurus
no Mr Lewis it wasn't an insult I I was
just saying that your mother's condition
is deteriorating because she's getting
older oh see that's cold though that's a
cold one okay okay I see how it is hey
y'all yo mama so old in her history
class they just wrote down what they was
doing
right
this isn't an insult contest not only is
your mother elderly but also her ability
to walk is currently being affected by
her weight oh see okay it just got real
no I'm not insulting her I'm trying to
tell you your mama is so fat
we should go to the movie theater [__]
that's the everyone
[Music]
listen to me okay your mother needs to
manage her weight or there can be some
real problems
yo mama is so fat she need a latitude
and longitude number to fight her old
[__]
[Applause]
now who's the doctor I Am the Doctor Mr
Lewis I am and it is my job to make sure
that your mother is getting the care
that she needs we are talking about the
woman who took care of you your whole
life the least you can do is take care
of her in her old age and take this
seriously
I'm sorry I'm sorry that I lost my
temper
no really doctor
I guess I was just joking around because
I know her condition is really serious
and
I don't know I guess Huber is the only
way I could really deal with it
I just know that she says so many times
she doesn't want anything invasive died
brilliant
I was not aware of that that's
interesting because she did not mention
that to me in our previous conversation
because
it was difficult to hear her with my
dick in her mouth
snap Mr Lewis
oh snap
now let's talk about the procedure
[Music]